we are back this is families
speaking of families my family is back
you know yeah
ela and theodore arrived
at 5 a.m this morning which means dad
didn't sleep
so tired so forgive me if i'm
sleepy you look sleepy yeah my eyes are
heavy
but we have a great episode here today
um sponsored by honey
babble and hello fresh okay oh and uh
important show announcement is that to
this week we're going back to the
schedule
we have families off the rails and after
dark we're going
it's all back yeah all the time baby so
everybody stop
worrying we're back okay
just when ela's gone things go off the
rails you know how it is we're back
one other thing real fast um is that
this thursday
we have a teddy fresh collection coming
out
teddy fresh on instagram you can preview
it here's one today
um we got these jeans look at this oh
wow
and this top whoops
is that high waisted um i don't
no it looks normal to me
um you know there's a bunch of cool
stuff coming out
uh follow teddyfresh on instagram to
find out when it's coming out but it's
coming on thursday 10 a.m
here we go we got cool designs beautiful
graphics
this is a floral embroidery
that says teddy fresh oh my goodness
classic you know what it is
get on over there teddyfresh.com and
terryfresh on instagram thank you
welcome back ela
also shout out to my mom who is rocking
the care bears but there's still some
left on the website
also my mom keeps pointing out and i
often forget that you have a pacemaker
or i don't wanna i don't
like but yeah you wanna show it off
my pacemaker yeah tick-tock people are
curious i can't is it usual where
you can oh my god it's so wild there's
like a big device
it is it's a device that keeps my heart
moving what's it like having a big
device in your body
it's uncomfortable do you get used to it
no really
no whenever i sleep it just digs into my
shoulder
i think that might have something to do
with this thing oh my god i've got a
bump here too did you get any news on
the bump
i talked to the doctor this morning what
did he say i have to see an orthopedic
doctor next
but they're not super worried about it
no i i will you know they have no idea
what it is
my mom's got a bump she's got a
pacemaker yes
but you know when my my mom had like did
they ever figure out what happened to
you i mean did mom have a heart attack
like what happened no my heart just
stopped
i didn't have a heart attack oh isn't
that what a heart attack is um
that's heart failure my my uh
nothing was clogged it's it's i have six
sinus syndrome and it's an electrical
charge thing
where your your heart isn't in sync
and so um it doesn't beat
correctly and my heart was going you
know
i don't feel like beating i'm just gonna
hang out a little bit
so it just would stop so
so this keeps it beating it gives it a
kick do you feel this when it shocks
your heart
do you ever feel it shocking away or
just doing its thing
if i'm real still yeah i can feel it
sometimes
really i have something else a cardio
issue where my heart skips a beat and it
starts
going really really fast that happens
yeah oh my god i'm gonna outlive
everybody i think so actually i gotta
and dad's bionic dad's got a new
shoulder and
i guess how does it feel to be older
we're falling apart
dad doesn't know yeah i forget you have
that pace my mom nearly died i thought
i honestly thought you were going to die
yeah i kind of thought i was scared it
was
for a while there was a few years ago
my mom was in the hospital uh
gravely ill you know it's messed the
surgeon actually did more damage than
the whatever the heart thing you had
in the end well i mean if i hadn't had
the pacemaker put in i
i would my heart would have just stopped
and i would have
you know died so he put it in but
you know because i'm so thin they
managed to puncture my lungs
oh god i forgot about so so they take
out like a buzzsaw they rush my mom into
the
hospital well i don't know how they do
it they rushed my mom in the hospital
and yes to safer they did save your life
but i did
i think they almost killed you because
that's when i was really worried about
you yeah they they cracked her chest
open
tear it open to get to your heart well
no they don't tear it open they just
you have like a cartilage
and they the doctor explained to me that
he was going to take it out
and then they kind of lift up your rib
cage
and then they kind of uh
there's two wires that go to my heart
the top and the bottom part of my heart
anyways they have to put like a straw
device
they they put it between your ribs and
and they thread it and it has to go into
your
heart and he scratched
the lung i guess when he was
doing that he punctured my lung and
because i have autoimmune disorders
my lung wouldn't refill
well i don't think puncturing the lung
is generally
something that you easily heal from
anyway no actually
when your lung gets punctured um
sometimes it'll just repair itself and
reinflate and it's not a big deal but
because of my
autoimmune disorders my lung wouldn't
refill and then
my other lung was starting to collapse
and and when i was in the hospital
they kept on taking x-rays of me
which i didn't understand and then uh
this doctor comes rushing in and goes
okay i'm here for the emergency and i
had already had my
my heart surgery i didn't know what's
happening i go what emergency you were
hard at breathing
you were having difficulty breathing at
the time yeah yeah you just figured well
i just had a major surgery
right right and he goes well one lung is
completely collapsed and the other
lung is going is losing
its its shape and unless you want to be
on a respirator
we need to take you into surgery now oh
my god and the nurse is well doctor when
do you want to prep her
and he said yesterday and jesus
so they whisked me away to the table and
they
they stuck a hose in me and then all
this
you know because when your lung is
punctured you get fluid and
blood anyways all that had to be emptied
out and then they tried to re-refill
your
thing where they put a tube in your
mouth and sucked fluid or no
no it was just into my lungs oh they did
it out of your back right
right right right right they they stuck
me
in with a needle and then they had to
take a small
tube into a bigger oh it was a bigger
tube into a smaller tube
i don't remember but the whole thing was
really out of your lungs through your
back right
right right right right but that was oh
god this story's so long it was just
crazy
but i'm glad i mean it was crazy because
i mean
a tangent from the from the pacemaker
but
yeah i just can't believe that you're
like back in good health because man
things were looking things were looking
really bad and
you just made such a amazing recovery
yeah it took about a year
but i came back i came back and now i
swim
back and better than ever instead of run
i swim
so so there you have it my mom's
pacemaker story
but better still by the way the moral of
the story is
oh the teddy fresh of the folks with
daddy fresh well thank you so much
the moral of the story in cases anyone's
wondering
is go to the doctor because you refused
to go to the doctor
as you sat dying in bed i thought i had
food boys
my brother your son how do you how do
you mistake food poisoning
for like heart stoppage i didn't sing
out she passed
you know yeah dad you you you disgrace
she passed out she was puking she
couldn't breathe
you're your dad who
called you and said he called my brother
who was living in vegas at that time he
said you need to go check on
well you know my mother you refused to
go
you refused to go to the hospital and
even when the paramedics came and they
said
if you don't go to the hospital you're
going to die my mom said no it's fine
i'll be back no that's not what happened
that's what happened
no yes it is they i kept on passing out
because my heart was stopping when the
paramedics were there
and when i came to the paramedics said i
needed to choose which hospital i wanted
to go to
and i didn't really want to go to the
hospital that's what i just said
what's different well he said to me okay
but you have to sign this waiver i go
what's the waiver for he goes so when
you die
yeah we're not that we're not we're not
responsible i go wait
what when i die he goes yeah you're not
going to make it
if your heart stops
you'll have brain damage and you'll
probably die and then
i thought well maybe i should i wonder
if that's a nice trick they use just to
get people to go to the hospital
they're like oh you don't want to go to
the hospital like okay well when you die
which you're gonna die
go ahead and just sign this yeah but
like what's
what i'm saying like i don't know some
people like my mom you've always been
this way
or adverse to seeing a doctor or getting
help
and so that's the moral of the story
because if your ass would have gone to
the hospital
before who knows what could have been
well you know in the past
i have had episodes where i was
sick the same thing happened and i would
pass out
and i just thought that was a part of
not
feeling good dad do you have a comment
on this
the other lesson i think is uh
don't need critical medical care in las
vegas
oh don't live in las vegas yeah well if
you need you know
there's well people love it there some
people not us but
oh you're the medical there is not
that good i don't think we saw ample
evidence of that
well unfortunately people that live in
las vegas probably don't have the option
of flying to los
angeles if they're dying that's true
so the tip is don't live in vegas well
unless you like to gamble you know what
so my heart doctor
the my cardiologist after when i had the
car when i had the tempinade
you know i went to the doctor a
follow-up they made me promise to go
to see the cardiologist after i had
gotten out of the hospital i was out of
the hospital for
what one day two days babe two days
because i had called
i called the emergency because i wasn't
feeling good at all
you got out after i got out and and
uh they i i think it was the next day i
went into
the the office and the regular doctor
that had
performed the surgery on me that
collapsed my lung was on vacation
and so um i was seen by another doctor
and they said um that's awesome just
punctured your longest yeah
everything was fine and i said oh by the
way i was
told when i was in the hospital that i
needed to take
an x-ray before i leave and so because i
was ready to walk
out and then i just remembered so they
said okay so i took the x-ray and then
the doctor comes in and
looks at me runs out again looks at the
x-ray
comes back and he says okay we got to
take you to the hospital now
oh my god i went what i just got out
remember so wait you went back to the
hospital for a follow-up x-ray
or i know i went to the just the the
regular cardiologists office just
to check this checkup right because i on
the pacemaker right because
my my pacemaker was on something wasn't
right and then
uh when i reminded them that i was
supposed to take an x-ray and i took it
and the the the doctor that was seeing
other patients
you know they said oh can you just look
at this x-ray really quick
for this one patient and when he saw it
he freaked out because my heart was
collapsing oh my
what does that mean i had so much fluid
in my pericardium
it's like an inner tube that circles
your heart right
and it filled up with so much fluid
around your heart around my heart that
it was squishing my heart
and my heart the right top side of my
heart was actually
collapsing jesus and so they said if you
don't get to the hospital now you will
die
how many times did you hear that oh god
well the doctor's office
is adjacent to the hospital yeah it was
right here in a wheelchair went down a
floor
went into the passageway into the then
you had to get another surgery
to drain the fluid around your heart
yeah yeah
yep yep that's crazy
yeah it was it was really i guess you
were crazy you guys could
i mean the woman that you sits before
you guys
i remember when you came to visit us
once and uh you were just
you were so frail and sick and just you
were in such bad shape and
you mean after the surgery the time you
remember when possible came over
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah i was really sick
oh god i was so sick
well when she came home that first week
i mean i didn't sleep i
stayed up and i listened to make sure
she was breathing
and i'd nudge her occasionally to make
sure she was still
you know conscious awake alive uh
because yeah it was it was close after
all of this
like what dad's describing my my lung
again filled up with fluid and i was
literally drowning
in my lung and uh when they dad was with
me they for some reason they let you in
the room when they they took a needle
and they
punctured the back thing i heard that's
really painful when they saw
oh my god that was so painful and they
took out
how many liters a liter of i think was
more than a liter was almost
two liters it was two big bottles of
blue
and [ __ ] no it was just like it looked
like beer
too it was just a dark it was good it
tasted good too
so but after that i was fine
wow i was fine i'm like a cat i think
i've got a few more lives left
well i'm just still amazed that you made
a full recovery so high five
mom survived i did mom living yeah
we love a living grandma
anyway teddyfresh.com yes steady fresh
that was a weird weird advertisement
okay we talked about saving the
monarch butterflies i do need to give a
disclaimer here
i know i was getting ready to plant a
bunch of milkweeds yes
and then we found out that they're
freaking poisonous
they're not that poisonous they're super
poisonous to small dogs and
and and children small animals and kids
that's not true yes it is true no mom
you got to be upfront about the milkweed
dangers
no you can't save the monarchs at the
first of all
you would have to ingest so much
of it like animals that graze
like you know like cows instinctively
for some reason they know not to eat the
milkweed because it's poisonous
but if they were left with no
food to eat they would eat it
and it would take so much for them to
get sick
it's a cow a cow weighs like 600 pounds
i'm just or more yeah i'm just saying
that it's dangerous to
pets it's not like oleander it's just
i mean it sounds like it is no it's not
it's not
it's dangerous i'm just giving you a
warning about the milk
you know i tend to milk weeds every day
and i've never
gotten sick you'd have to sit there read
me an excerpt on the on the milkweed
because when i was looking it up it
sounds like if your animal or
child gets into it it can be really
dangerous you would have to eat so much
milkweed
and besides you can plant it in the back
maybe it's not going to go in the back
oh yeah teddy's not gonna go in the
backyard no not in the backyard
yeah teddy never wanders around the
backyard
no it's no more poisonous than oleander
no
that's not true milkweed contains
cardiac
glyco glycosides that are poisonous to
humans but the level of toxic
toxicity toxicity
it depends on the species first of all
and how old it is
how toxic is milkweed all right let's
find out
if you planted milkweed for monarch
butterflies you may be wondering just
how toxic
they are for people and animals milkweed
contains all right just what i said
poisonously blah blah blah
blah depends on the species according to
the agricultural research and
development or center of ohio state
university
common milkweed is slightly toxic to
humans but only if eaten in a large
amount
well maybe i'm hungry maybe maybe
theodore's out there and he's feeling
hungry and he sees the milkweeds and
he's going for it
he would have to eat milkweed may cause
losses at any time but it is most
dangerous during active growing seasons
several species of milkweeds are
poisonous to range
animals to range animals
i think you didn't point out the
difference between
indigenous and foreign milkweed that's
true too
so that's kind of important indigenous
milkweed i'm telling you these monarchs
want to die
they just they want to die like they
don't so here's no it's not it's not
toxic to them they i know but they want
to die don't you understand they have
one food source
and it's poisonous to everything else on
the planet
it's not poisonous to everything like
what is with these monarch butterflies
couldn't they find a more
a more sustainable thing to eat i found
a stowaway a moth that was living off of
the milkweed and he was like
i had to kick him out because he was
eating the plant well it worked for them
for probably ten thousand years till
humans came and started
uh digging up all of the milkweed and
they were never gonna make it
they were never gonna make it for them
they need to make it judging by the
comments
mom got uh yeah everybody's on
everywhere everyone
i just want to say that i i feel morally
obligated to say
look into the milkweed situation all
right what did 9 11.
and good do you want to clarify the
indigenous
aspect yes of that if you go to
nurseries
the usually what you can find is the
tropical milkweed
and you know it's tropical because the
flowers are yellow and orange
of course and california's uh
indigenous uh milkweed is white
flowers and pink but for some reason
fascinating they don't
they don't sell them at the nursery you
have to get their seeds
i've got seeds growing oh you got seeds
you got seeds for days well
not for days i used them i already
planted them i sent dan
pictures of my of my milkweed anyway
i i don't think theodore or the dogs are
in
the habit of just eating random plants
but i just have to say
because i don't want anybody being like
i tried to save the monarchs and now my
dog is dead
i just got to put it out there that's
all i'm saying watch out for the
milkweed people have dogs and they've
got a growing in their gardens plus you
can put it in pots
and and you know you don't just saying
okay do you want to
quickly wrap up what's wrong with
putting tropical
oh my god guys okay need to finish that
okay go ahead with the tropical moment
well because like anything else
that that gets into the the ecosystem if
it's not
indigenous it takes over and you don't
want to worry
even though we're giving them a problem
the problem is is that the tropical
milkweed doesn't die back at the end of
the season
so the monarchs stay they stick around
kills them
no it doesn't kill them they just they
just stick around so they don't
fly off to mexico where they need to go
so the the regular milkweeds
you know died back and then they go okay
you're making this hard now
you got to get the right milk weeds or
the monarchs die you know what you can
use regular
whatever they sell at the at the at the
nursery just cut them back at the end of
the season or if you want to keep your
monarchs
get the tropical and they'll just hang
around your house yeah
this monarch saving business is way too
no i have all my i have all of my
milkweed in pots
because i don't have enough dirt in my
backyard
all right you want to do you guys want
to do some slang
sure okay here's your bonus let's
introduce you to some
some slang first and then we can decide
which one's going to be your 100
bonus today okay are you brought notes
i i always bring things it's always
interesting
i should get a pen so i can write down
okay here what what
is king [ __ ] king [ __ ]
like let's say s-h-i-t dad dad washed
the dishes he was on some king
[ __ ]
um some kind of high
king [ __ ] a high as k-i-n-g
motivated some kind of like dad brought
home the good milkweed
he's on some king [ __ ]
on the good list when a man does
something
good he's doing king [ __ ]
all right i got most of it there king
[ __ ]
how would you just how would you i i get
it but i'm trying to figure out how i
could
[Music]
define it he's just doing a good deed
he's on something he's doing what he
should do he's a king he's a king he's
on some king [ __ ]
okay bestie you know the best he is
yes best friend yeah thick
with two c's t-h-i-c-c
thick someone who's heavy or
well it's more specific than that mommy
muscular muscular
it's it's fat and all the right places
creating
sex okay your royal thickness you could
say
[Laughter]
big mad big mad
big mad that's a really man i planted a
fan planted milkweed in the backyard and
his dog
ate it and died he was big mad at me
yeah really mad
really yeah big mad big man extremely
pissed
okay that's easy vibe you guys know what
vibe
yeah drip this is a good one trip
like he's a direct drip not that he is a
drip
what does that mean he's a drip yeah
meaning he's not
he's like um
is that a weirdo a drip someone who's
who's
like no it's used as an adjective so
he's got
no charm he's a direct dripping or you
could say he's got drip or he's dripping
expression too meaning someone who's not
really with it or not that's what i just
said
style kind of out of it he has no
charisma it means the exact opposite if
someone's
got drip it means they've got a badass
outfit
ah or swag okay drip a drip she's dr
you would say to ela like i'm dripping
in my jeweler
yeah i'm dripping in my you're dripping
you're dripping hard with that
i even say you're flexing on me with
this whoa yeah
okay so let's do today our
our bonus word for the day could be
no i think either king [ __ ] or drip
what do you think dan uh
i think king shit's gonna be easier to
find a way to weave in
i don't think we're doing any fashion
reviews today okay so let's do king [ __ ]
okay okay all right that should be easy
[Laughter]
to remember king [ __ ] okay so today
i have a special assignment for you
actually we're doing are you smarter
than a fifth grader
oh god we're doing advice and we're also
going on omegle to make a friend for you
because i figure you got into a tiff
with your friends from after the last
episode you guys kind of had a fight
about the straws
and about vaccines and you there was
some drama
a little yeah maybe yeah all on my side
yeah exactly but regardless i feel like
you know
maybe it's a good opportunity for you to
look for some new friends
and so i want to go so there's just old
friends no but i know but you can never
have too many friends you can never
have too many friends that's true and so
there's this website omegle
oh megel where you connect to it and
you match with random people
and so i'm thinking let's set you up
these are just for friends right this
isn't like
no it's not for sex it's not a dating
site or anything
it can be whatever you want don't look
at me i have no idea what it is
okay what's it called driggle
and so we're going to connect to a megal
and your assignment today
is to make a genuine connection with
somebody
i want you to exchange emails or phone
numbers and then
actually make a genuine connection with
somebody where you can follow up with
them and be friends with them
after the show okay all right sounds
very dangerous well
yeah yeah it can be that's part of the
experience right well just give them
ethan's address be honest
let's be let's vet them you just say for
yourself if this is someone you want to
be friends with or not
i mean because they can tell you
anything that you want to hear
yes they could i'm being difficult just
give them email you don't have to get
you don't have to give them the phone
number
okay so so try to exchange emails that's
safe we come from yeah
let's say with emails is there anyone
over 18.
of course of course dad how dare you
like i said i don't even know what it is
before we get to that my dad
did bring in a mystery link for me
i don't know what it is i'm gonna open
it
so i don't know my dad's got some kind
of mystery beef or something
so here it is
okay i think that says it all right
there
this is uh kind of in response to
some of the back and forths and some of
your
grievances many of which are justified
about
my lack of being father of the year a
few times and
issues that we've had back and forth um
you know which i've taken some grief for
online
i was out surfing the web as many 70
year olds do
and looking for ethan's name and i came
across
a podcast you had done uh two bears in a
cave with your friend
uh who's tom segura tom segura thank you
uh and i watch it was very interesting
nice to get a different perspective
and oh no i know what this is because
ethan had said my dad never taught me
anything
we never did anything fun all he did was
take me to baseball games and stab
beach balls with knives never we never
did anything good never learned anything
so
i was watching this podcast and towards
the end something interesting came
up that i thought i'd like to share just
to maybe
give the fans a different side of
ethan's upbringing okay fair enough it's
only fair
i know exactly what this is and i knew
you were going to love this so here it
is
shout out to my dad
and please notice he always feels to me
i was just going to say
ethan struggles to even say this as he's
about to say
my dad so i wanted to point that out you
always feel to me like you have a
real like clear moral compass
like i feel like you're a good gage for
like right and wrong i've i've even
asked you like you think this is the
right thing to do
and like what why do you think that you
don't fear what so many people do which
is like getting on the bad side of
somebody with influence oh [ __ ]
autism i don't know
i had this all the way down mom ruined
your moment dad
[ __ ] yeah thanks cancel it cancel the
video did you guys work this out before
we started shooting
oh my gosh i actually hit dial on my
phone
all right i'll go back a little bit dad
so you you get all the you get all the
props
i don't know why do you this is gonna
cause a real fight after the show
dad's gonna be like why didn't you mute
your phone tom
continue please think that you don't
fear what so many people do which is
like
getting on the bad side of somebody with
influence autism i don't know
high functioning autism
i i don't know what's the answer yeah
yeah no that's a legit answer
i wish i knew i mean if i'm thinking you
know
grow i i don't know i feel growing up
there was like um
that was like a big part of like growing
up mm-hmm
it's like do the right thing always do
the right thing yeah but you do
i i i always read that from you thank
you i try
and it's always like do so so there's
that part of me
and i think there's another part of me
that just doesn't like to take [ __ ] from
people
there we go so okay shout out that do
the right thing dammit thank you
that's kind of important that's an
important lesson i would say do the
right thing
oh absolutely thank you for that was one
thing you hammered into me
all right and another one was do as i
say not as i do
that i got from my parents do the right
thing damn it thank you that was
actually a really interesting question
from tom because i've never been asked
that
and i was like i don't know
yeah people don't really stir [ __ ] like
i do and
it doesn't scare i'm just i don't know
why i guess maybe i should be more
scared of it
i am being sued like i am being sued
right now
and they just added a new complaint too
which should be fun
so really yeah we're going to talk about
that this week
well when you do the right thing you
feel good about what you're doing and
you
believe in yourself until someone sues
you till feels good
until the consequences come yeah he's
going ryan cavanaugh aside we're going
to talk about he's going after ila and
teddy fresh
what i know it's [ __ ] awesome what a
dick
it's water why why they made this really
thin it's not thin it's non-existent
argument about how
teddy fresh is an alter ego company
based on
nothing alter egos when somebody sets up
basically a fake company to hide their
assets and make
them personally unlock rely on it's so
not true
exactly it's based on literally nothing
so it's just like more scare tactics and
intimidation and trying to scare us into
thinking like that
what a wicked man oh thank you mom i
agree i mean
that's one way to put it yeah he's going
after eli klein
elast company teddy fresh that's just
wicked
i can't even it's wicked it is yeah
that's a good word for it what is wrong
with him
ryan kavanagh well um
i'm not a psychologist but like probably
i mean
i'm mommy i'm gonna give him a diagnosis
but like i mean he does look like harvey
weinstein
we'll get into that later yeah all right
that would do it
you could start by diagnosing harvey
weinstein and then saying well he looks
like him
anyway um yeah we're gonna go to break
when we come back my mom is gonna be
finding new friends on a megal and i
can't wait
this would be interesting this summer
get the most out of your travels abroad
by learning the language of your
destination with babel
the number one selling language learning
app from ordering in restaurants or
asking for directions
gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture babel makes the whole process of
learning a new language addictively fun
and easy with bite-sized lessons you can
actually use in the real world
babel is a can't miss travel essential
mom mom when you were in mexico you used
it
to learn spanish i did before we we left
for mexico
i i was studying with babel and it
really
helped me get on the road to start
learning
really yeah you were saying how like
they keep using the same words
they do you the lessons right and so you
keep on
get you get words reinforced because you
continue using words that you've already
learned
genius even the babble's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go
and unlike the infamous language classes
you took in high school babel has
designed
their courses with practical real-world
conversations in mind
things you'll get used to in everyday
life other language
learning apps use a.i for their lessons
but babel lessons are created by over
100 language experts their teaching
methods have been scientifically proven
to be effective
and with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel's
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation
and actions yeah and there are so many
ways to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes let's go
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
nice that's six months for the price of
three
just go to babel.com and use the promo
code families
that's b a b b e l dot com
code families for three extra months for
free
babble hello fresh what is hellofresh
you may ask even though you know what it
is
because we've cooked it and it's
delicious yes it is and that looks
really good yeah
ian ian made that one look at that that
is like
unbelievable that looks so good i'm
actually getting hungry and
ian was raving i'm not even kidding ian
was raving about how good this was
it's great so it's great i'm a little
bit bitter that i didn't get that one
what is hellofresh it you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
you skip the grocery store you get the
perfect amount so you have to buy like a
huge bushel of like cilantro for like
two pinches you know what i mean
and it makes cooking at home easy fun
and affordable and that's why hellofresh
is america's number one meal kit
hellofresh cuts out the stressful meal
planning and grocery stores
trips with less prep less effort and
minimal cleanup
so you can enjoy the experience of
cooking and get dinner on the table in
just 30 minutes
hello fresh's calorie smart options
also make it easier to enjoy tasty lower
calorie meals this summer
if that's what you're into without
scouring the grocery store for
ingredients and the web for easy recipes
come on they get it all cooked up from
you
you can choose from 50 menus wow 50.
wow choose from 50 menu and market items
each week from vegetarian meals to craft
burgers and extra special gourmet
options they're all available
something for everyone to enjoy with all
the recipes designed and tested by
professional chefs
and nutritional experts to ensure
deliciousness and simplicity
you know i i've always loved hello fresh
it's super fun
and it's like they said you get to enjoy
the experience of cooking there's a lot
of stress surrounded with cooking with
like
going to the grocery store wrapping up
recipes and they they cut out a lot of
the stressful things and they just
make it fun makes it easier when you're
working and you know you're getting good
ingredients yeah exactly i mean
cooking is it's it's a big commitment of
time
so here's what we love okay go to
hellofresh.com
families14 put another one for this time
and use code families14 why are we using
14 i'll tell you
you get 14 free meals wow
plus free shipping what let me repeat
that for you because i didn't
go to hellofresh.com families14
and use families 14 for up to 14
free meals plus free shipping so
uh hello fresh is america's number one
meal kit for a reason honey honey
why are we chanting honey from the top
of our lungs
it's because honey is a miracle on the
browsing
internet today all of the internet has
culminated into this moment
where you can click in two easy steps
add the honey extension to your browser
and then you're always saving money no
matter what you buy on the internet it's
magic
it's simplicity it's the beauty of honey
we all shop
online and those promo codes they've
taunt us at the checkout and i'm not
having that [ __ ]
with honey i don't have to worry about
getting taunted because what honey does
is it manually searches for coupon or no
sorry it
automatically scours the internet
for coupon codes at checkout it's free
it takes two clicks to install they're
supported by over 30
000 stores online ranging from tech
gaming products popular fashion brands
and even food delivery
it's everywhere guys imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite stores
you go to the checkout honey drops down
with that's beautiful little drop down
and it says apply coupons
you wait just a few seconds honey
searches all the internet for a coupon
and bob is your [ __ ] uncle if you
don't know that you just saved a bunch
of money
for literally doing nothing this happens
i can't emphasize how often this happens
when me and hilar are shopping
clothes shoes whatever it is it's
usually clothing
because either buys a lot of clothing
let's be honest um
and it's like you're just you're
shopping you're getting ready to pay
full price and then all of a sudden
honey comes down with like a 25
that's that money yeah it's crazy you
know i'll tell you how much it adds up
they've found its 17 million members
over 2 billion
in savings that's a lot uh hit the jeff
bezos laughing uh
thank you dan so if you don't already
have honey you could be straight up
missing out on free savings it's
literally free
and installs in a few seconds and by
getting it you're going to be doing
yourself a solid
and supporting this podcast so we love
that
great i wouldn't recommend something i
don't use and trust me i use honey all
the time so get honey for free
at junehoney.com families
it does that's the that is it right then
yeah it says the wrong thing here so
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
families that's join honey.com
families okay we're back and we're about
to go on omegle so
my mom doesn't know anything about
omegle so the first thing you should
learn
is that even we are on um the
monitored side of this right um
there is a chance a good chance that
you're gonna see a man's penis today
what dan's recommended and i'll try my
best to avoid that happening
oh i don't think i like this segment no
it's going to be great i prom i'm going
to do my i'm going to work overtime to
make sure you don't see any junk oh look
like dan said if you see someone
covering the camera with their hand
there's a good chance
the junk is coming oh my god okay
why do they even have this website this
is this sounds
very people connect with men's penises
oh
god all right let's see though this this
is good this is
this is good right dan
good to start yeah yeah all right
i acknowledge blah blah blah nobody
cares nobody reads
confirm here we go all right mom here's
your first friend
oh that's weird wow that was weird
i'll talk to her it looked like
someone's arm my dad was interested
what was it well they moved on already
okay i swear if someone just whips it
out and i'm just like
hey guys what's going on
oh are we on the radio are we on the
radio
um you're not on the radio no but we are
on a youtube show
featuring my mom oh they've burned down
the radio well they're just stupid
enough to think radio has
specialized radio
since windows mom's gonna find out and
we're gonna be in trouble
hey dude bro i know you were in that
robe you
you're singing a couple dude don't lie
to me you're about to whip your [ __ ]
oh god i don't want to see this
dude why are you wearing a robe you're
making me nervous
this is this is so so sick i can't hear
what you're saying oh he's british
that robe is is
yeah oh lord what what is this
ethan this is this is i'm trying to find
you a friend
i'm not sure these are the friends i
want to hang with
okay here we go hey dude
i put down the phone man we're trying to
make a connection bro sounds like a
horse race
it says there's 53 000 plus people out
there and i keep getting all the douches
hello no that's me that's me
oh my god what was that they said that's
fake
i think maybe they recognized you and
thought it was a troll
no troll here my mom is hi oh my god
that kid was like two
he was so young where's teddy
this is so bizarre
oh my god we're getting absolutely
skipped on
wow nobody wants to talk to you well
yeah i'm a 65 year old lady who the heck
wants to kill i mean it's kind of an
interesting looking
situation you'd think people would be
curious
dude it's what the [ __ ] it's all spam
dicks
it's crazy out here hey dude
hello is this life hi we are i hope
you're not gonna whip
anything out no no i
can say that normal person oh thank god
it's incredible to meet a normal person
on here how are you
i'm so glad to see some actually people
me too yeah yeah how are you what are
you doing go
ahead mom i'll let you connect wow well
we're on a podcast my son's podcast and
he thought it would be a
a great way for me to meet new friends
and uh you're the first normal person
that we've uh come across
thank you you're a second
and so um why what com what what do you
guys have in common maybe
i don't know well you look a lot younger
than i
i am are you in school are you do you
have a career
you're probably gonna be surprised when
i tell you my age people
don't believe me but i'm 35. he's 35.
okay
that's the same age as your son that's a
great that's very interesting
okay almost i'm 36. okay
what's your name may i ask oh okay
uh do you know the female name valerie
yes so in my country we have a male
version there so i'm valerie but male
version but
it's easy to call me vel val like val
kilmer
uh yes sort of and and val do you like
butterflies
um let's ask myself
about that but i never asked yourself
that well my mom loves butterfly do you
have any ques
well i i don't know i think we have
probably have separate interests but
um well i'm very peaceful person
yeah well all right val let's cut to the
chase let's cut to the chase valve let's
see your [ __ ]
no please oh god he's kidding that's a
joke
it's a joke have you been to the united
states val have you been to the us
okay i can make something uh on my my
paper
it's kind of fake how many times have
you been to the us have you been here
never all right so we're at the point
my mom doesn't want your email address
valtteri you're a nice guy
you're very nice there wasn't a you know
uh
you know girlfriend that's
that's amazing that someone with his
intellect
would be spending his time on something
like this
mr master of accents thank you pegged
eastern europe yep
you know who else would give us that run
he said yes
well that's eastern europe russia it's
more like
asia a big cut oh wow russia is a
gigantic country
russia is literally asia it's like an 80
of asia
by land mass we're all eastern european
my grandparents came from lithuania
which would be
russia right now no it wouldn't
lithuania is his own country right now
all right well that was good we made
some progress
yeah we're looking for a girl yeah i
don't think it's going to happen
we're not going to find a friend for you
no i don't know
dude you're [ __ ] in the head bro dude
you're really sick
you're a sick [ __ ] bro shame on you
and to show his face too like damn um
hey hey man how are you
oh nope i haven't seen one
i think you're the only one now
you sick [ __ ] i just want to shame all
these guys and make them rethink
rethink your life dude rethink
everything you're doing right now
why are they doing it you're you're
disgusting
what you're doing is not okay you should
feel ashamed and you need help i don't
even know what i'm looking at maybe it's
a good he's looking at the roof because
he's got his [ __ ] in his hand
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] off you're you are
disgusting human being
there's kids on this app and you're
willing to show them your dick you need
serious help you need to talk to a
professional
you need to reevaluate everything you're
doing you should feel deeply ashamed of
yourself
what do we have to do to get demonetized
i don't think we've done it
what is that what am i looking at dude
all these people are all freaks
and this is the moderated side too
there's a moderator not
well let's go to this children oh lord
what are your children doing on this she
knows you
you can make friends with with a young
girl looking for a role model
yeah but i feel fearful for her with
what we i agree with
well ask her what she's doing here i
know how come you're on here
what did she say hello
may i ask you guys a question please we
can't see you
they're hiding my camera's too high this
is a mom
would you like to say anything to the i
think women i think you girls should not
be on the
that they should they hunt they don't
have it there's somebody
yeah show me something i don't want to
say oh here you go mom
hey oh my god another a normal person
yeah
this is a normal young lady
how are you oh what a burn
oh no [ __ ] was that great bestiality
bass pro shop it's all i need to see
dude i know you're a douche
i saw the bass pro shop hat bro you
can't hide it oh my god i saw the hat
bro
don't try to act like you didn't show it
it's a pretty small hat if you're
covering up your junk with that dude
you're
good wow this is gee let's go to the
unmoderated site
i didn't want to know bro i know exactly
oh my god this is the moderated site
you know who are these parents that are
letting their children well they don't
know
they don't know nobody's letting anybody
on here isn't there someone who can
block
it that's crazy
um are we sure we're on the moderated
side i don't even know what that
is yeah i think so what's up you [ __ ]
sick creep
i know exactly what you're doing you've
psycho what is that he's covering the
camera with a blanket cause guess what
he's got his dick
hey dude get a life wow get a life
hey freak i know exactly what you're
doing
this is kind of fun just shaming all
these people
oh god hey dude hi
wow it's a normal person so nice to see
you lord
how many penises have you seen before
you got to us how are you
so far so good very good where are you
from
you know what dude peace and love but
i'm out
i knew that wasn't going anywhere yeah
so see what happens when you assume i
know you're jerking it i love shaping
these
lunatics at least
okay that's well that looks real
yeah and that's on the moderated site
that yeah i know i i can't imagine what
you're doing
why are we doing this this is fun oh my
god
okay sorry how are they allowing hey
dude
i didn't expect it to be such a [ __ ]
show oh my lord
but now i'm too committed to the segment
oh god i'm not committed to this segment
at all hold on maybe hey dude
uh oh no
dude you're such a [ __ ] creep
i just like hi that says
los angeles uh los angeles it does say
los angeles
that was fake that was a fake stream hey
you sick [ __ ]
i just like to say that i think someone
watching porn
is much safer to society and to
themselves in general
yeah shout out for porn compared to
oh yeah yeah oh totally all day this is
especially like teams
can i ask you a serious question what is
wrong with you man
you seriously are disturbed if you're on
here can i
see her bobs he wants to see her boobs
mom or bobs
can i see her bobs
dude you got to get a life bro i mean
really get your [ __ ] together
[Laughter]
hey dude you're sick [ __ ] you gotta get
your [ __ ] together right why
why right now get your [ __ ] together
oh you don't have your dick out he looks
unconscious
he he's hiding in a closet you don't
have your dick out right now
i don't believe that no no
okay what's going on man good for you
why are you browsing in the dark it
seems kind of odd
he looks like he's in his pajamas
i like that peeling the peeling paint in
the background and that
in that place oh my god
well that's someone that wasn't naked
probably it's a kid
they're children oh my god maybe i
should try to
add a tag back this is terrible that
there's chocolate
[ __ ] strongly advised to uh to use the
tags
okay let's try to do significantly what
it is is the amount of uh
penises you will see yeah wow oh it
worked immediately hey guys no
they know you we are live look who it is
we're real
we're real peaceful you're
joking stop can i take a picture can i
please take a picture they know you
no photos you have to email me money
no you can take a photo i'm just kidding
of course you can okay i
really thought i'm sorry i oh my gosh i
mean i'm filming you guys you know that
right
who is that yeah i don't some fans i
think there's some fans of each other
do you want to you want to talk to them
well you know
who are you guys yeah what how come you
guys are on this site
my mom's worried about you i am i'm
really worried we were watching you know
what
yeah we're just trying to find some
chill cool people
just some cool people to hang out well
then you're not going to like us
wow wow that was harsh
that was really hard well he said he's
looking for chill cool people and i
thought
not us hey dude donna what he
thinks yes i know but it's inappropriate
dad is getting on my face for more i
know what to say don't worry dude
it's an interview this is an interview
you're being interviewed right now
what are we looking at is that the floor
on the ceiling
whatever it is i'm not into it there we
go
hi my mom's trying to make a friend
oh my god brutal hello
nobody wants to make a friend with
someone's mom they're doing the tick
tock tag you think they want to be on a
show that's the whole point
i got to skip people [ __ ] hi guys
hi this is my mom she wants to be
friends with you
who is that i don't know but they're
excited
mom talk to them why are you so excited
why are you girls so excited
there's nowhere
no no we're from families
i'm the frenemies guys wrong show
families
your family don't get to know my mom at
all this is families
mom ask them a question i uh how old are
you guys
no not that we don't want to know you
don't want it you don't want to know
that
we have another question what are you
girls i'm not going anywhere
hey hi my mom wants to be friends with
you
how do you know somebody looks like
they're tired
are you sleepy it's 12 14 a.m
it's 12 14 a.m this is my mom she's
looking to make a friend on omegle so
here you go
hit it off wait so okay oh
hey dude not our type oh that's too many
oh ethan this is a terrible segment this
is
awful we're getting closer though we're
getting closer
the fans will be the judge of that oh
lord
hold on let's find one more good i'd
rather be talking to to little puppy
dogs or something
i'd i didn't realize that was on the
table
oh my god you [ __ ] monster oh
god that was so gross
trouble hey did you call me gross we
were watching something from a previous
woman gross oh you called my mom that's
my mom actually i [ __ ] you
then i am very sorry because uh you know
mom you are beautiful
because i was about to go off on you
buddy if you you don't want to know that
someone before you was showing their
private parts
mom can i have your sniff jelly well
that's why we're here actually
why do you have a brillo pad on your
head to me
that's not nice gary he wants you he
asked for it
no no sorry that's a no for my mom's
you're not hurting how much how old are
you how old are you
i'm 65. no would have been better
if he guessed oh really you look pretty
good
he wants to do a 69 with you apparently
oh you know what dude you're [ __ ]
you're a pig bro you are disgusting how
dare you speak to my mother that way
hey dude oh this looks promising
lord oh you sick man
you are sick don't want to see hey dude
no
no what are you on the floor what is
this back on the floor it's designed
really on the floor cheat vinyl you got
there
dan thinks it's funny it's got it is fun
it's good i want to just find one
genuine connection on all of them
we have to find one genuine connection
this is not
good king [ __ ] give me this give me a
case
i'll [ __ ] you no he wants a kiss he says
give me a kiss give me kiss suck my dick
i was like okay
i'm watching spongebob okay cool enjoy
that
spongebob my generation
oh my god did you see the uh h3
teddy fresh collab with spongebob maybe
we could have sold some uh
you want me to sling some merch yeah
sell some merch hey
no no no no how close are we to seeing
your dick right now on a scale of one to
ten
[Music]
yeah ten ten stop
this is torture hey man he knows you
my mom's trying to make a friend you
want to say hi to my mom
[Music]
hi hi you know what it looks like one of
those
beanies on your head that's spinning
with the fan on the ceiling
it's right above them doesn't it it's
like the inspector gadget kind of
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's got to be one
of those
you know who is it i think i might know
you
you might i think you get one guess
you get one guess are you h
h two h two h two h you're one off
one three number h3
all right we'll skip on him you got it
wrong hi
my mom's trying to make a friend hi
hi girls how are you
i'm i'm good you girls are i don't know
where
you are are you having a sleepover what
is it seems
pretty dark behind you it's my birth
it's my birthday today oh happy birthday
happy birthday
congratulations what a nice uh what a
nice day for you mom would you like to
uh i don't even know what to what did
you get for your birthday there you go
um i got a picture of me and my dad
so recently um my dad had passed away
with cancer
oh i'm so sorry to hear that i got
a picture of me and him oh my goodness
that's great
where are you what part are you in the
states yeah you you speak english well
are you
are you an american yes okay so how
how recently did your dad pass away
sounds like pretty recent
november wow i'm so sorry to hear that
my goodness well
it happens it happens
wow what do you say to something like
that i don't know well i
you know i i hope that that you take
this experience
and it it keeps you close to your mom
and that you you know you
uh you take his memory and keep it with
you forever
and and excel in everything that you do
and have nothing but good fortune thank
you
she sounds like a mother doesn't she
yeah well you know
so what do you guys do anything else fun
for your birthday
um we're going out to eat at this place
by my house
we did this painting thing oh yeah we
did like a fun painting thing
so we have these like canvases my sister
set it up and stuff
and like we start painting on a canvas
and then we rotate and add to somebody
else's campus
oh that's fun that sounds fun yeah can i
do something i don't know if you know me
i'm i'm on youtube kind of a famous guy
kind of a big deal
if you google ethan klein or h3h3 you'll
find me
i want to buy you a birthday present oh
that's so sweet again
you don't have to no i want to buy you
something special
oh no google me you can see you can see
that i'm a real person
that's your sister next to you there say
your name again ethan klein
h3h3 production k-l-e-i-n
yes and so you guys don't think i'm a
creep or something but
you know what it sounds like it's such a
special birthday for you
and i just feel like i really want to do
something special
for you did you find him did you find us
look under the podcast
h3 podcast families mom
[Laughter]
i think what do you want free what do
you what's something you you want for
your birthday like uh
like if you could have anything you
wanted for your birthday like a gift
like a physical gift what what would you
like
i don't really know okay
well what's your favorite store to shop
at
uh american eagle air hostel okay
i'm gonna get you a heat i'm gonna get
you like
well you know i bet you some of the
teddy fresh like these shirts would
she would like oh yeah daddy fresh well
i'm not trying to sling my merch
no i'm just i'm just scared
you know what um i'm gonna you email me
i'm gonna get
buy you a thousand dollar gift card to
american eagle
oh wow wow i want you to have a good way
i really do want you to have a good
birthday he will do that
please i want to do that for you well
follow up and and
write it right down my email is write it
down get a pencil and paper right now
wow happy birthday happy birthday and i
want you to
go and have a really great time shopping
and buying whatever you want them yeah
thank you yeah you're welcome okay so
send that email okay
happy birthday to me okay
happy birthday guys happy birthday thank
you so much
yeah bye girl you're probably the nicest
person on here
well yeah yeah you know what you
shouldn't be on here there's a lot of
weirdos
that was so nice of you that was very
king
you were on your king ship
[Applause]
wow i'm just giving out money everywhere
you actually nailed that that was a
perfect execution
perfect executive good job
wow well that's about as good of an
exchange as we could have hoped to get
out of omegle so
all right enough for megalo
i've given out enough advice on omegle
to all the guys out there
good let's give out let's give out
advice that people are actually
asking for okay i'm ready and
everybody's favorite
ask mom
dear mom you really want to be your
dear abby well i do you like dear abby
was that something you were into as a
kid because you bring that up a lot
i do yes really um
no not really i mean i you know i i
don't i don't think i read or call them
dear mommy like dear abby yeah a little
weird with
the mommy okay yeah let's just move
forward all right
[Laughter]
okay sorry about that how to be okay
with my boyfriend never wanting to get
married this is an interesting question
hi donna and ethan both of you are
married so maybe you can help
my boyfriend and i are in a stable
committed relationship we love each
other and work well however he says
marriage is never going to be on the
table
he had divorced parents and his first
marriage failed he wants
us to be completely separate i said um i
suggested just a name change
no legal wedding and that too was
crossing a boundary
he said he will never buy me jewelry
because he sees it as proof to other
people
of his love he says we are already
family nothing else matters am i just
being silly
about how upset i am you want to
crack at that well um
first she has to ask herself a question
which
is people are joking by the way that
your advice is always dump them
no no no well you know
she has to ask herself a joint one step
dump him yeah
no she she has to ask herself does she
want children how does he feel about
that
okay because that's that's an important
issue you know there are some famous
people like
goldie hawn and kurt russell that never
got married
but they are both financially wealthy
so they don't care you know it's not
like your average
joe where you are invested in your
financial
stability and and and lean on each other
uh for security there's also gene
simmons
and what was your name why does it
matter if you're really
famous people are married or well
because they're they're so
wealthy that to them they don't care
like
you want to be fine if not who cares
but they did both of them had children
and you know they have
normal from what we can do from what we
know
um is she is she being silly about how
upset she is
no i don't think i could handle being
with the man who said that to me i mean
not even buying her jewelry that's
that's the part that was a red flag for
me it's like
i understand that he has trauma and uh
um uh commitment issues right
he has his parents he got a divorce once
it sounds like it must have been really
traumatic for him
his parents were divorced i'm assuming
at an early age that can be really
traumatic
and so at to a certain extent i can uh i
can empathize with somebody saying
you know what i'm happy to commit to you
but i don't want to get married okay so
i get that
but the part where he loses me a little
bit
is when he says he's not even going to
buy you jewelry
see that that to me is like makes me
think like well
what is that about well plus you know it
depends on where you live
i know california um
observes like if you if you're you know
common law marriage from a different
state i'm not sure if you move in
together in california
if it's considered common law but i mean
he wants to keep
everything separate um their finances i
mean it's almost like
you know friends with benefits that's
all it really
is well that's kind of harsh but you
know no seriously i mean
well they're dating they're dating a
friend with a benefit is someone you
just screw and well didn't they say that
they would live together
didn't they just buy they committed did
they buy a house together what did they
say
no nothing like that
oh well
i thought oh you have notes
i have confused it wait what it read
this read this
read it again you want me to read the
whole thing again read the whole thing
again
she's in a relationship with her
boyfriend right they're stable
committed okay however marriage is not
on the table
his parents were divorced right he wants
everything separated
i suggested a name change with no legal
wedding he says no
to that he won't even buy me jewelry
because he sees it as proof of other
people
so they're not even living together
that's uncertain
i'm assuming they are why would you
assume that if everything's separate i
think she just means like banking and
stuff like that
here's my advice i dump them
we need to dump them
no you know it it's like he's got issues
he's got issues i i mean i think that
when a man falls in love with a woman
that's the bottom line and he's not
going to say that
it's like do you not want to get married
do you not want to get married to me
i wouldn't go that far he can be in love
with you
he has got a lot of trauma and so
you're going to have to make a decision
you know
these are lines he's cros he's
clearly laid out and he's told you he's
communicated to you
very clearly these are my boundaries so
in one respect
we have to appreciate that he's
communicating his boundaries to you
so now the ball is in your court are
these boundaries that you're going to be
able to live with i don't know how old
you are how many more
how much longer you have to find another
partner stuff like this stuff kind of
enters in the equation a little bit if
you're young you know
and this is something if you want if
getting married means so much to you
the big question is do you question his
love and loyalty to you
right because if you do then everything
else is performative
is this someone you trust to be a
lifelong partner to you through thick
and thin
then you know if if you're questioning
that then
then i'm with my mom and we're going to
say hand on the button
[Music]
yeah that's a toughy though are you is
it silly how upset you are no of course
not it's you're not it's not silly i'm
so you're at all
you're completely entitled and the fact
that you are upset
shows me that you're concerned in some
way
about the legitimacy of the relationship
and because he's
so clearly laid out his boundaries i
wonder how old he is
yeah i don't know i'm afraid for these
the long-term stability of your
relationship i agree dad's raising his
hand
i know this is the mom answers gives
advice but
i see the problem as he has no skin in
the game
so at any time he could just say okay
we're done by
out so there's no there's no investment
on his part in the relationship it seems
like
right right well that's where it comes
like do you trust this person to be a
lifelong partner or is this someone
you're afraid he's just gonna skip
out and so look look
being married doesn't mean it's like
commitment is is uh an emotional thing
being married doesn't force anyone to
stay
you know right it makes things
complicated if you want to leave but
like
ultimately do you trust this man it
seems like you don't
yeah and the whole thing with i'm never
gonna buy you jewelry [ __ ] that
that's that's so busy you don't want to
get married buy your girl something just
show commitment right yeah
i'm sorry he he needs to see a
psychiatrist
oh my mom coming in with well he's got
issues
you know what i think i think we're
going to see this guy's dick on omega
couple years i don't know
all right next one oh what is it creepy
boss
uh oh my boss is a man in his mid-50s he
constantly talks about what a cool guy
he was
sounds like michael scott right off the
bat
i was such a cool guy and he tells
stories about his youth that are similar
to something you find in an old 80s
movie if you needed a dictionary
definition of incel he'd be the perfect
candidate
he asked if female employees have nudes
on their phones and if he can see them
he also asks if we know what
only fans is and if we or anyone we know
has
one he saves pictures of our female
employees on the work
laptop without thinking anyone can see
he's a creep that's really bad at hiding
it
he defends bill cosby and other serial
predators by saying he doesn't
understand how someone's so rich and
famous needs
to drug girls to get them i'm already
looking for a new job but i feel so
guilty leaving my co-workers with this
guy
i want to make a report but i'm scared
he'll know it's me what should i do
tough well you want it you want to take
a crack at it first
sure sure mom um well you know
first of all there's so many different
levels
of of of creepy
and and someone who is harassing you at
the workplace
and so how do you rate that i mean well
first of all
he hasn't physically you know
touched her well clearly there's no hr
that he must be the
the owner of the company otherwise if
you have a human resources i mean he's
done so many things
that would get well you don't know that
it's hard to know you don't know
that you know he
it's like he walks the line you know
where he knows he can't
physically touch them otherwise he's in
trouble although you know
he's way over the line he's way over the
line yeah you know i was like he's way
out this morning
dad had stephanie miller on the radio
and there's uh
dr wendy walsh she's got a
podcast on iradio
and it's called mating matters and she
talks about a lot of these
different issues she actually was a
model when she was young
and um she was molested
by by the guy that was the boss of the
way you wrote that up
like williams thing no i mean and she
she talks about the different levels of
being okay so what's this creep guys
what's the
creep level on this guy on a scale of
one to ten in your opinion
well she needs to
get out of the environment it's not a
healthy environment that's
that's definitely free if that's her
boss
what should i do can i
well if there's someone above him she
can certainly
talk to uh his superior but if he's the
boss
if he has something to that that ruins
you know
her uh her professional
uh
um what am i what do i want to say i
mean you know
he could a lot of people can can go
ahead and put out a word and really
really stifle your your ability to get
another job
she's afraid that's what she says she
says
i want to make a report but i'm scared
he'll know it's me
here's what you need to do this guy's a
sick [ __ ]
she needs to leave there's a lot of red
flags in here
most of all is asking females for nudes
yeah that's that's even worse is saving
pictures of female employees on his
desktop that's creepy
um this guy is off
this guy is he's a predator he might be
a predator
based on what i'm seeing like he hasn't
touched them but
right i don't know if that's something
that's on the table
but regardless of his touch i mean this
is not just not a safe
and working environment so i understand
you wanting to leave
and i understand but here's the thing
this is a sticky situation right where
it's not really putting you in a fair
position because on one hand
you it sucks that you're gonna have to
put a stick out your neck and
potentially deal with the consequence
of this guy either trying to prevent you
from getting a job or whatever he's
gonna do
about you that you're afraid of it's
like the
it's like the victim mentality of like
right you
if i i now now i feel like i have to
protect the people that are there
or i'm going to feel guilty for just
moving on and not so you're in a shitty
situation
what is this what's what what what do
you do what would you do
well unfor i think the right thing to do
is to say something
right because ultimately you're kicking
the can down the road for someone else
to potentially become a victim of his
but
you know it's [ __ ] up because he's
putting you in this position
so you know why why do you need to risk
your neck for something you didn't even
do
so like the right thing to do is to say
something
the safe thing to do is to not say
something so you know
and and by the way it's like i don't
know what this guy's capable of
so it's hard for me to say the cost of
doing the right thing in this case or
not
but i'm not gonna blame you for just
moving on because a lot of people don't
want to deal with this [ __ ] and frankly
it's his [ __ ] fault so
those are the two options the right
thing and the safe thing
well a lot of times guys will say really
stupid things they're just
weirdos and they are creepy beyond that
though
you're giving him a benefit of the doubt
he doesn't deserve
he's saving pictures of the employees
yeah that's kind of creepy
he's asking if they had new photos they
can show him if if there is a superior
oh you know someone above him i think
she should
have a talk with his superior if he's
the boss
then she needs to just you know without
saying anything just put out her feelers
and try to find another job
and as far as her co-workers that are
left behind
they're aware of what's going on if if
she's had that that experience so have
they
yeah we'll talk to them you know i mean
because obviously
that's not a good environment and if he
is not
yeah that guy needs to go man that guy
is a danger too
i don't think if if the if if there was
someone above him and they knew that he
was
he was acting like that that's a lawsuit
waiting to happen oh for sure
you know they need to get rid of him so
she needs to be honest
if there is someone above him well
that's what i'm saying
this is the right thing to do and the
same thing to do
and ultimately you're gonna have to
weigh the pros and cons of what to do i
don't know
i really don't know dnc versus principal
the truth is
that if you move on and don't say
anything and this guy ends up assaulting
someone or doing something like that
you're going to feel guilty
and my thing in life is the oh i don't
ever want to feel guilty about any
decision i ever made
so i i like to move forward with a clean
conscience
so whatever's gonna make you move
forward
thinking like i did the right thing and
i'm not gonna feel guilty about what
this guy did to other people
no it's not your responsibility but
personally that's my advice do the right
thing
[ __ ] this guy you'll find another job
and if you have an hr department they
will keep you anonymous
right like this guy never heard of the
me too well i think i don't think she's
in that situation she seems pretty
certain he'll know it was her so
depends on the size of the company well
it depends on who's who's
i mean if if whoever's in charge above
this guy
if he's a real bozo too look uh based on
what she said she says he's probably
gonna know it was me
okay so thank you
peace and love good luck with that [ __ ]
that guy that guy's a creepy
[ __ ] dude yeah that's
what a douche men are gross sorry damn
anyone
except for the good ones except for the
men on omegle
of course the men on a mega are the only
good ones out there oh
god oh freaks
men are such freaks jeez how do you even
date how do you even be with men what a
disaster
you have to keep propagating the species
we gotta you put it yeah you kiss a lot
of frogs
that drive women are saints man they
just they do it all they carry
they carry the whole of humanity on
their back we do
[Laughter]
all right here we go real foot
fetishizer oh this is
this is interesting all of my life i've
always had a thing for feet
lately the media has been making it out
to seem like foot fetishes are bad
and i've become too scared to tell
anyone that i have a thing for feet
should i continue to hide my fetish or
just come out of the
closet as they say or in this case the
uh
well i think if he's dating
a woman i don't think he should come
right out and say i've got weird food
uh foot fetishes until he dates her and
he
realizes that she likes him and they end
up
going out a couple times and then he
needs to come out of the closet and be
honest with her
she needs to come out you need to tell
her now
could you take yourself i mean how
how when you say foot fetish yeah like
how
fetish yeah how much are we talking
about yeah because like if you're
being intimate with a woman and you
start doing stuff with her feet
i don't think that's a big deal like i
feel like that's in the realm of like i
mean a lot of it's like a little outside
normal but it's enough to
just to like handle but are we talking
about like
yes mistress like you're at a restaurant
you're like yes mistress
that's a little weird like we have to
you know what i mean some guys like to
paint their
their partner's toes i have a feeling
that's only the beginning of what this
is
you know but i mean if he wants to do
something
sexual with her feet maybe she'd be into
it exactly he needs to just be
honest with her my thing is like feet
fetishing is something that i think most
of all the fetishes that have
i feel like this is one of the easiest
to digest for your partner like if you
want to do weird [ __ ] to her feet it's
like i don't think she's going to object
to that if that's what you're in well
yeah and if she does
and he's okay all right there's limits i
can go so far with you and that's fine
i don't think that i think you're good i
don't i don't think you need to work i
don't know
just go out with her i mean do you have
like i don't know and then
you're talking about you have pictures
of feet all over your house because
that's bad that's hard to explain
because he makes it sound like it's such
a big deal are you in defeat are you
like
how in defeat are we talking no you
don't need to be scared i think i think
and also
foot fetish fetishism is
very popular i mean in terms of i know
that like there's a lot
a lot of guys are just like wiki feet
hello yeah we have a society that has
wiki feet so how forbidden can it be i
actually don't think you need to be
embarrassed by this i think if you just
say i'm in defeat
you know i think that's off your shoes
that's fine you know people some people
like sniffing farts and [ __ ] so like
yeah oh god oh god you're pretty good
yeah
pretty good i wouldn't worry about it
well what do you mean come out of the
closet do you need to go around
announcing you have a foot fetish no i
wouldn't recommend that i mean you know
keep it to yourself to a degree
nobody wants to know you know i don't go
around saying that i like to uh
don't say it i mean if a guy said to me
i i love your feet you've got beautiful
feet i think that's a compliment yeah
you know and if he says oh you know let
me paint your toes and i smell your feet
okay then it starts getting weird but
but you know
i mean if he enjoys painting your toes
it might be an exotic
experience i'm pretty sure but if it
gets if it gets really
interesting then that's up to the girl
if she's okay
or not no just just like just be like yo
anyway you're good dude trust me don't
worry about it man you're fine
you know are you chopping feet off like
why is it so serious you have feet
in your freezer i'm just saying there's
different varying levels of foot
yeah yeah just keep your [ __ ] together
you don't yeah
he doesn't sound like he's that off the
chain
well it's only three sentences so who
knows yeah yeah
you're good bro just just enjoy yourself
find you a girl with some crazy-ass feet
that you can just get weird with you'll
be happy for life
okay i need advice hi donna and ethan
how do i tell my boyfriend that he has
approximately zero months left to
propose
until i'm out of here we've been
together for 4.5 years
and living separate the entire time we
recently moved in together and things
are doing great
we love our house we are enjoying
cohabit cohabitation
i have a nagging thought in my mind that
i've only prolonged the inevitable by
moving in without a ring i'm afraid that
i may be giving the wifey
special when he's only signed up for the
girlfriend experience i'm tired of
waiting
okay when
jessica your your ethan's sister
was young i always used to say to her
you know what
if you want to move in with a with your
guy that's fine
but put a ring on it but she didn't
she moved in with brian i moved in i
moved in with a way well before we were
right things are different uh
you know what if she is in love with him
and he is in love with her
and she feels like i want to get married
you know story which i think i've
told before so if i'm being redundant
you'll have to indulge me a little bit
well tell me we'll cut because i don't
want
okay we're not here to tell stories like
that time's over
dad dad and i when we were you know we
were dating
two and a half three years and every
night we would say good
night to each other and i hated it i
just hated it and finally i just said
marry me so she doesn't have to wait for
him if she feels that strong about it
then ask him to marry her you know and
if he says no she needs to find out
is he just not ready or he just doesn't
i mean it's the mere fact that they've
moved in together
i mean you're saying communicating so
there's some key facts left out here
you're saying he has
zero months left to propose have you
guys talked to proposal
have you asked him if you if marriage is
on the table
obviously communication is the key to
everything what should you do i mean
talk to him tell him
you gotta get [ __ ] married you need
to know how committed he is
the clock is ticking it's time to make a
family as a man i don't get the whole
commitment issue i really don't
understand these people like
if i was with somebody and before ela
all of my girlfriends were somebody that
were like i knew were fine and fun for
the time
but i knew i didn't want to marry them i
would never move in with somebody like
that right i would never progress the
relationships
to the point of moving in together if i
knew that there was no long-term
prospect in fact
i know i wouldn't even date these people
for for more than like six months in a
year because it's just pointless right
you're wasting everyone's time until i
met ela
i immediately knew this was someone i
wanted to marry and so everything else
fell into place easily right
i don't understand guys that you're
gonna spend four and a half years
together
you're gonna move in together and you're
not gonna want to get married like
i mean what what is wrong i just don't
understand that well that's right
that's why i don't think that she should
come at it
with like an ultimatum like
well it sounds like she doesn't want to
waste another day well that's why she
says
zero months left to propose out of here
she has no more patience so that's why
i would say instead of waiting for him
to ask you
ask him and if he's if he says no
you need to find out do you not want to
get married
period do you not want to get married to
me are you waiting to save money for a
ring they just moved into a house
i mean there could be a number of just
just say look you know that's not a bad
idea i know it's not romantic i know
it's not what girls dream about everyone
wants to think these big beautiful
romances
or probably look i you guys don't i gave
him the ring to eel and a pack of baby
wipes okay
it doesn't matter the moment doesn't
matter it's the life that happens
afterwards
so don't get caught up with all this
romantic [ __ ] and fantasies
just say look [ __ ] are we
getting married or not
no she doesn't have to say it that way
just be well sweet and say i love you
don't say that verbatim but yeah say i
love you let's get married
if he says no or he's not ready you know
give him a few days to think about it
and if he's not changing his mind then
it's
peace one love see your dick on a mega
loser
dump him right dump no no
no no no no no no no no dump no dump
dump them how much more time should she
have tested
what do you wait well she needs to ask
him to marry
he said ask and if he says no dump him
you got to move on well if if he says he
just doesn't want to get married then
yeah
yeah then he's just gonna what if he
gives like another [ __ ]
non-committal
answer like well you know let's just
wait and see
stuff like that well give him a timeline
and then
well she said zero months zero months so
what do we say to him
well if he's not stopping but if she
asks and he
and he declines for
you know all the wrong reasons then what
are the right reasons
he's saving for a ring how long is he
saving four and a half years
how old are they you know i mean if
they're young
dump dump dump all right dump them yeah
thank you
but after everything advice on where to
store sex
toys this is interesting oh there's no
place to hide
dear ethan and donna my wife and i both
love your podcast so much our questions
for
your too is where would you suggest we
store our sex toys
so what happened to ethan doesn't happen
to our own children that's a great
[ __ ] question
okay that's actually a really good
question yeah well there
you know i hid things
i thought pretty darn good massive dildo
i found was not hidden well it was
it was it was it was in a sock it was
hidden in my drawers in the top drawer
next to your bed that's like the first
place a kid's gonna look for weird [ __ ]
you know what the only way you're going
to keep your kids out of your home no no
no they'll still find it i swear
jessica's better than the drawer next to
your bed
lock it up you just have to have a
[ __ ] some kind of say
you're doing it you have to lock it up
you have to have a lock it's like a gun
they're going to find it right put it in
your drill it is true in your gun
yeah you got to put your dildos in your
gun safe that's set
there's no kids will get into as i have
learned
you know everything yeah you need a gun
just just
lock it up that's actually that that is
kind of the only right answer if you are
that afraid
as you should be yes of kids finding
your gun
your sex toys you're gonna put those
you're gonna yeah you're gonna have to
lock that up with your gold
and uh weapons yep they find it
geez i just unbelievable
that's amazing though the thought of
having like when you're ready to like
get into it
you have to go to like a safe well keep
it up
you're gonna need to know this because
you you've got one on the way
and you got teddy 20 dildo oh gosh
it's not valuables i can only imagine a
hundred years from now they're crack you
know how they like find saves in old
houses
they're like we're gonna crack open the
safe there's gonna be lots of money or
checks or relics and they open it up
which is a [ __ ] dildo
oh god what the hell yeah that's the
only thing that's going to be safe that
you can be
absolutely sure of you put it in a burn
proof
uh unbreakable scenario right fire
yourself years from now
aliens are there's going to be some
archaeology done
when humanity is wiped out and the
second humanity 2.0 evolves
they're going to come to the rub of your
house open this relic can you imagine
when you die and your kids have to go
into this
yeah right now i save it put it in a
safe
good advice thank you well guys that's
about it we had are you smarter than a
fifth grader but we'll do that we'll
save that for next week
i'll probably trivial well well you can
have dad like well dad's good at trivia
yeah i don't want to go up against dad
he'll
he'll destroy me but you can have the
dad lifeline
okay that sounds fair so next week we're
gonna do are you smarter than a fifth
grader
okay and um next week so can i get my
report on my butterflies
how many do you how many times well i
wanted to i wanted this this is the
butterfly show dan can you just show the
one pic
i just wanted to show somebody all right
okay just go to the
to the chrysalises
while we're doing that i'd like to reach
out to the uh
young lady who sent me a message i think
it was on youtube who had worked at a
uh i think in chicago somewhere at a
ballpark
who was booed as were all the other
ushers when they tried to take balls
away from people and she's her job that
reached out to
support me and say thank you for doing
that
you don't have to take the boo she's
paid to take the boo
i know but this is she appreciated his
seeing a car accident and pulling over
to hell it's not
at all it's exactly really like that
exactly
anyway reach out to me again with the
information so i can
mention you next week if ethan lets me
thank you
with peace and love you're so funny
all right what do i got to open the
butterfly [ __ ] oh god it butterfly [ __ ]
well it's like you know
i mean god bless them but come on i just
wanted to
inform our viewers of something that
they can do
okay so let me let me open it my discord
was closed
all right we have butterfly updates um
the pet poison helpline reports that
milkweed is moderate to severe poisoning
in dogs and cats
which means get to the vet as soon as
you suspect your pet has ingested the
plant
i'm telling i'm just saying
that was what ian sent me well okay
yeah thanks ian yeah and now everyone's
gonna go oh
they're not gonna okay so if you look at
closely
this chrysalis this caterpillar had
attached
himself to a leaf on the plant
and what happens is sometimes
caterpillars with ferocious appetites
eat the leaf
and it could dislodge the leaf and the
whole chrysalis could fall
the first day a chrysalis is formed
there
it's wet and you have to be careful and
let it be
but as soon as you can what i did is i
cut the leaf i don't know if you've got
a picture of me holding the leaf
ethan this is all i have i think okay
you cut you know you hold on to the leaf
and you
cut it and i had you know a towel
and i gently laid the chrysalis down and
i used dental floss
and what i did was i tied a loop around
the very top including the
the leaf and once it was it was
safe i tied another knot so it leaves
like a loop
you know and then i took a pin a
straight pin
and i attached it carefully to the top
of the cage and so the
chrysalis is safe it won't get dislodged
and fall
from the plant and it'll stay there
until it's ready to be born
this is the photo it's pretty blurry but
let's see well that's me holding
after i cut it and then there's one
showing well i mean that's pretty that's
pretty hot you could write a book about
this [ __ ] mom you're pretty good at it
well you know you lay it down i even
have a picture of me
tying the chrysalis this is pretty cool
i'm done
you know see you can see that so it's
nice and safe
i mean you have to be careful there's
there it is you make the loop first
oh we're working oh we have instructions
so yes yes
so this one right here which dan's got
to send me it
okay i wish i got
half as much care and attention as this
butterflies
i rubbed your head this morning when you
woke up
don't give me that all right i'm set for
the next month your father and i chase
each other around the bed we like to
cuddle okay gross
that so you can see you can see the
the dental floss around
the chrysalis that i'm i'm about to tie
and well you can figure it out well it's
there for you
you know i really want to help but i got
so paranoid about the milk we
don't get paranoid i'm worried i can't
have poison back there no
it's not that please i mean
the worst that could happen is they
would get an upset stomach
it literally i just read it says oh i
said it says
moderate to severe poisoning and dogs
and cats
as soon as you suspect that's from
that's from healthypawpetinsurance.com
yeah pet insurance here i'm going to
show you something that i
i sent you yeah from save the monarchs
that's like these people are corrupted
no and of course the smaller the dog the
greater exactly and we have tiny dogs oh
please
the info you got is from
savethemonarchs.com or whatever i mean
this is
these people are are here's see here's
the different types of milkweeds that
you can
that you can plant i'm just saying it's
it's there's some risk there
i don't take any risks the worst thing
that could be your dog would throw away
you want to know the truth
i would rather every monarch butterfly
die than
shredder gets sick oh that's terrible
just the truth
although milkweed contains
rarely butterfly and shredder dying i
would kill them all in heartbeat and i
do it every day for the rest of my life
it rarely poses any significance to my
dog
i know i'm on your side [ __ ] the monarch
butterflies
it rarely no i'm gonna get i'm gonna get
hate for saving my dog
no it's he's not gonna get butterflies
wanna die
they just they wanna go rarely poses any
significant
threats that's from the monarch website
these people are
are brainwashed this is not this is not
uh partial information
if you're that concerned put it on the
website put it into the website
put it in a pot lies
monarch joint venture exactly
funded by the monarch uh save the exact
big monarch money
put it in a pot and leave it somewhere
high up
if you're concerned about your animals
or your children
you know or in your case you can put it
way in the back where
teddy doesn't go teddy goes everywhere
teddy doesn't climb up way up on top
he goes everywhere oh please he'll get
into everything you just talked about
you have to put a sex toy in a [ __ ]
vault
and he's not gonna get to the milkweed
how about on the hillside across the
street
i would happily put every monarch
butterfly in an incinerator and
cause mass genocide on every model you
know what i don't
understand oleander people put that you
know
right in our driveway the people next to
us
there's a giant oleander see that's one
thing i think you guys are exaggerating
no it's gigantic no i think i don't
think oleander is as dangerous
oh it's way dangerous no there's been
many cases oh my god people
died and cooking stuff and okay we're
going to get an oleander branch and
it's that point you just take a branch
of olander
stir a pot with it and you will die you
can you will die yes
oleander is very tough that's weird
because it's like everywhere yep
it's like was in our front yard like a
huge bush it's like all over the place
there's a huge bush right outside in our
driveway
it's huge that that is true i've always
heard that about olly anders they're
very
they're very feel like it has to be
overstated how risky it is because
how prevalent no no no you can't fact
check it when i was a realtor
if i was showing someone a house and
they had kids and there was oleander you
had
especially in the backyard i'd say if
you buy this house you got to pull this
oleander out because it is deadly
yep yeah it's true extremely toxic
extremely toxic okay so but why are you
skeptical about this because why are you
dying on this
is oh no because this is like it sounds
like old folks tales where my dad goes
they used it to stir a stew no and
everybody died a single leaf can kill an
adult human
boom well why is it everywhere that
seems so insane
i mean lots of plants are toxic you just
don't eat them yeah well
here in southern california they put it
on the medians of the freeways it
doesn't need a lot of
water flowers it looks good
we don't care if some people kill the
milkweed
no the milkweed isn't that weird
i'm an anti-monarch but if you can get
monsters you're not gonna plant milkweed
now well i'm scared for the dogs in
theodore
ethan i'm just i'm scared go right up
the hill and just plant
california's doing like a billion dollar
milkweed foundation 10 million but
what if you could get the monarchs to
eat oleander instead of
milkweed then that solve your problem
then i gotta plant only in there in my
backyard
no can't they just eat like [ __ ] uh
ivy
you know what i'm saying like figure it
out they don't
eat ivy they eat milkweed how about eat
like uh
an oak leaf dumbasses
a daisy ivy is mildly poisonous by the
way
oh get that out of here there's always
you know plants that's how that's their
defense they have to be somewhat
well you know a lot of plants milkweed
is not
if if teddy were to put milkweed leaf
in his mouth i nothing would happen if
shredder ate
a gob of milkweed he probably would end
up
getting really sick but he wouldn't die
okay
doctor let's take a chance yeah again
i'm sure yeah i'm sure you know exactly
what would and he's not and he's a
veterinarian and
you know what it it probably would taste
awful he wouldn't want to even eat it
well that's there's only one way to find
out
guys thank you for watching frenemy
families
family strike that yowza
families
thank you for watching families we'll be
back next week
as always with are you smarter than a
fifth grader are you smarter than a
fifth grader
god i hope so i'm saying yes going out
on a limb
yeah i think you do i think you don't
well we'll see we'll see um
so thank you guys once again regular
schedule that means off the rails
and after dark coming as usual
teddy fresh on instagram thursday 10 am
you know what it is
thanks for watching smash that like
button ciao everyone